do you win when you do it have you won
yeah I'd be big J what do you think I
was gonna lose the big Jay oakerson
can't crowd work a [ __ ] bros battle I
would do very well I bet you would think
so yeah hey look at that beard way
bloated a bunch of crooks come in last
night and take your razors out in a
satchel box roast battle I'm really good
you are yeah you have any more good want
to sir
hey hey hit Sam Hill real hard right now
hey man look at the hair on you what did
somebody take a sponge curl it up and
make it into some kind of a head
covering and stick it on your head
Berrien oh dude look at Adrian over
there oh look I'm sitting there Adrian
wait for it where's Rocky show if you
treat me like this no you're right I
don't wanna I don't want to hit you get
out of here yeah yeah it's not good it's
not good to just bury the guy I mean
I've already slammed him well dude I
came on someone's hand once I went to
Tijuana great opening for a chapter my
friend didn't want to go to Adelitas
that one strip that one I've never been
there I know I know I want to go Chiana
once you're in softball is it
promiscuity there's some you don't yeah
but my friend was like I don't want to
go to one of those nice nice uh [ __ ]
houses I want to go to like a back alley
you want to like get like a 12 year old
and he said he said the one he did get
he didn't go to that low but he did they
wanted to go he goes you could tell she
was a mother you tell he goes get her
kid was watching us anyway but I was
like you better come with us and he goes
I'm not going to him but if you don't
come get a hooker with us I'm gonna come
on your hand and he was like no or not
anyway so then I ended up coming on my
hand and then when we got downstairs i
high-fived them two flights of stairs if
I get a handful of Combes friend again I
would you'd hate that he wasted it right
and doesn't hit you in the mouth of this
[Laughter]